there's a lot to like an ant man in the
wasp but the newest offering from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but it's
definitely not without its flaws we're
here to take a look at what worked and
what might have worked a little better
these are the five best and five worst
things about Ant Man and the wasp best
dad of the year some of the best moments
in the film are when Paul Rudd's Scott
Lang is hanging out with his young
daughter Cassie
played by a B writer Fortson the
chemistry between Paul Rudd and Fortson
is exceptional with Fortson bantering
with red like a seasoned professional
it's hard to believe the two aren't
actually father and daughter in real
life and with a relationship this strong
to anchor the film everything else comes
together beautifully worst
previously on ant-man ant-man and the
wasp is a sequel to ant-man as well as
Captain America Civil War so there's a
lot of story to fill viewers in on
unfortunately the first several minutes
of ant-man in the wasp are bogged down
by clumsy exposition from Hank and hope
sitting down to remember the plot of
ant-man - Randall Parks Jimmy woo
rehashing the plot of Civil War and age
of Ultron it's a lot of rehashing from a
writing team that is capable of more
interesting things best ghosts isn't
transparent Hannah Jon Commons ghost
doesn't even seem to realize she's a
villain and that's because her
motivation is pretty simple survive your
quantum powers are tearing her body
apart and she doesn't have long to live
in putting our heroes up against a
villain whose goal isn't world
domination but simple survival the film
feels fresh and distinct from the 19 MCU
outings that precede it who is the bad
guy in ant-man and the wasp we have
opponents but not necessarily villain
worst they can't all be winners on the
other hand Walton Goggins appears in the
film as a shady black market tech dealer
named sunny birch and the role is
everything ghost isn't well ghost has a
compelling backstory and clearly defined
personality birch is about as bland as
they come the film is saved by ghosts
antagonistic menace but it's hard not to
regret seing Walton Goggins wasted and a
forgettable role
best Michael Pena steals the show the
best tyst in the original ant-man isn't
Scott breaking into Hank's house it's
Michael Pena's Lewis stealing the show
he shines every time he's on screen you
got their credentials he's in the system
this is Pena is once again a standout in
the film packed with memorable actors
his rapport with Michael Douglas's hank
pym is still delightfully awkward and
they even managed to work in one of his
sloppily narrated stories I first met
Scott even self-id
and I was like unbelief and he says I'm
Scotty and we're gonna be best friends
wherever ant-man goes in the future
here's hoping Lewis goes with him
worst congenic catch a break Janet's
disappearance prior to the first film
pushes tank into his angry reclusive
state and screws up his relationship
with his daughter ant-man and the wasp
has the opportunity to undo this while
giving one of the great Marvel
characters her MC you do instead it just
trades one trope for another making
Janet one of the film's primary
MacGuffins when she finally appears in
the end as she gets maybe five minutes
of screen time janet and michelle
pfeiffer
deserves better best low stakes high
reward Avengers infinity war took the
MCU to the highest stakes the franchise
has ever seen and came on the heels of
an Asgardian apocalypse and a wakandan
revolution luckily ant-man and the wasp
gives viewers a bit of a break from the
ridiculous tension of the last MCU movie
the fate of the world isn't at stake in
this new ant-man adventure at its core
ant-man and the wasp is about the fight
to save the lives of two people ghost
and Janet Van Dyne
it's a comparatively small story but
just what MCU fans needed after infinity
war worst time is money these days most
blockbusters have a runtime of over two
hours
even though longer isn't necessarily
better with comparatively small stakes
and such a simple story to tell a man in
the wasp is absolutely a film that would
benefit from a shorter runtime even the
director himself agrees I'm very vocal
about amm movies being under two hours
unfortunately it comes in at over two
hours longer than the first ant-man film
Doctor Strange and even the first two
Thor movies you'd think a movie about
shrinking heroes would know that bigger
isn't always better
best laugh it up in the past MCU movies
have had a bad habit of incessant
quipping even the previous ant-man movie
did it it's ok as funny as ant-man and
the wasp is there isn't a single
important dramatic moment in the film
that gets interrupted by a character
making a joke or a gag going down
serious moments are given the time to be
taken seriously and that makes the
comedic moments even better worst
character matters the MCU excels at a
lot of things but its best quality might
be its ability to take characters and
make them grow organically from film to
film unfortunately this is ant-man in
the wasps biggest flaw Scott might grow
as a character but it's literal growth
not emotional he ends the movie in the
same spot he ended in the first ant-man
romantically involved with hope and no
longer in immediate trouble with the law
meanwhile hope experiences a significant
life event and her mother returning from
the quantum realm but the film never
really shows us what this means for her
past the initial reunion despite the
size changing neither character gets a
chance to really change us people thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]